[Music]
welcome back to Lawton crime daily it's
week two of trial for Adam Montgomery in
New Hampshire he's the father of a
missing five-year-old girl who's
presumed dead this week the girl's
stepmother testified against her
estranged husband as part of a plea deal
this is the first of two trials from
Montgomery in this case he's charged
with two counts each of being an armed
career criminal receiving stolen
property and theft by unauthorized
taking prosecutors accuse him of
stealing two guns from a couple's home
and trying to sell them in the fall of
2019. the crime allegedly happened just
months before The Disappearance of his
daughter Harmony she was last seen alive
in late 2019. that's when investigators
believed she was likely murdered but
Harmony wouldn't be reported missing
until two years later her stepmother
Kayla Montgomery pleaded guilty to a
perjury charges last fall She's accused
of lying to a grand jury about Harmony's
last known whereabouts as part of
Kayla's plea deal she was required to
testify against Adam in his Firearms
trial prosecutors also agreed to drop
her own stolen charges connected to the
case here's how her testimony went down
when she took the stand on Monday
the incident that you're describing had
were you already aware at that point
that the guns had been stolen from the
foreign house
yes and you said people had come to sell
drugs yeah was that to you or to someone
else
to Adam but I was going to be doing the
drugs too
okay so they came to sell drugs to Adam
you were going to do the drugs as well
yes and it sounded like you said he
offered to sell them the the firearms
yeah to trade
them or buy them
buy the Firearms or trade them for drugs
okay so he had them at that point and he
was going to trade them or sell them for
drugs yes trade them with for drugs or
sell them for money
at that point did you know what he was
wanting to get for for them
no I had no idea because I don't I don't
know I never dealt with that before I
just let him
deal with it because I don't know
adamant is scheduled to go to trial
again later this year this time for
Harmony's alleged murder investigators
believe the five-year-old died in
December of 2019 after Adam punched her
in the head repeatedly authorities say
Adam then destroyed or concealed
Harmony's body within three months of
her death Germany investigation
prosecutives believed that Adam
attempted to quote induce or otherwise
cause his estranged wife Kayla to lie
about the case leading her to these
perjury charges Harmony's body has never
been recovered Adam was indicted in
January for charges including
second-degree murder which carries a
life sentence on its own Adam is
pleading not guilty to all charges the
murder trial is set to begin in August
and is slated to last about a month
Terry do you think Kayla's testimony
helped the prosecution at all I do you
know when she first came in and she was
testifying you know she had the prison
uniform on and she was very slow and it
was very drawn out and I think that they
may have lost the jury a little bit
during some of that testimony but from a
substance standpoint she really did make
the points that she needed to make she
knew where he stole These Arms from she
knew because he told her that he stole
those guns so I think that the jury
really from a substance point they
understand that he did take these guns
and so that's the charge here obviously
the real big charge is going to be that
second case Brian that you mentioned the
murder charge but it does seem as though
she was very influenced by him and
that's why she lied now she has this
deal with the prosecution she did her
part she got on the stand she testified
and she was factually accurate it seems
to me
Mark with the result of this case guilt
or not guilty have any impact on
Montgomery's upcoming murder trial
a conviction here can't be used to prove
anything in the murder case but I will
say this I've spent time in New
Hampshire it's big geographically but
it's like a small town this is big news
in New Hampshire all the details of this
case are being seen across the media
these are the potential jurors in the
murder case and this does not look like
a good place to raise a child so whether
there's a conviction or not in this case
this evidence and its media coverage is
going to create a very difficult
environment for this defendant in the
murder case coming up this fall yeah the
court of public opinion always has an
effect on jury selection that is very
true thank you for that point mark well
when we come back a former Child in
foster care is suing the state of
Arizona for dismissing sexual abuse
claims that spanned over a decade up
next we'll explore why the state says
they're immune to consequences
thank you
[Music]
we're finishing Today's Show in Phoenix
where a child sex abuse victim is asking
a judge to decide a negligence claim in
a lawsuit against the State of Arizona
we want to warn you this story is very
disturbing 20 year old 20 year old
Trevor frodsham was in foster care in
his entire life he says he was sexually
abused by his foster father for 12 years
starting at two years old to the age of
14. Arizona allowed the Foster Father
David to retain custody and even adopt
other foster children despite over a
dozen claims of misconduct the state
said the Department of Child Services
investigated the complaints but couldn't
prove them to be true David frodsham was
a civilian Commander working with the
U.S army he was eventually arrested in
2016 for leading a sex abuse ring he
forced multiple foster children to
perform sex acts on him and his friends
sometimes in the presence of his wife
Barbara David is currently serving a
17-year sentence in prison defendants
and Trevor's lawsuit include the State
of Arizona his foster parents the
Department of Child Services and other
agencies additional claims in the suit
include a solid battery and intentional
infliction of emotional distress the
judge will have to decide whether to
make a ruling on the negligence claim
and have or have all of the claims go to
the jury that decision is expected to
happen next week the State of Arizona
claims that they and the Department of
Child Services have what's called
qualified immunity and cannot be held
liable for the decisions they made in
this case we had a chance to speak with
an Arizona attorney that is representing
some of the foster children who had to
live in David's Home here's what she had
to say about the case
there's videos of him having sex with
his adoptive son they try to make these
arguments that a convicted pedophile who
disseminates porn Kitty porn only likes
one kid out of the whole house I don't
think so
but what the real defense of the state
and the licensing agencies to Cobble
together a very confused argument on
qualified immunity they try to make the
judge feel sorry for these poor workers
and the conservatives are very very into
protecting police officers I don't know
why they apply this to people who are
paid to take care of children criminal
defendants who are quote being treated
unfairly by the police they have a right
to a lawyer a right to a trial they have
all sorts of six Amendment rights Fifth
Amendment rights these little children
have no one
Mark horrible horrible case
um what do you think of qualified
immunity being applied here does does
the state not bear some responsibility
potentially but let's remember when we
sue the state we're suing ourselves uh
this lawsuit was taxpayers to pay these
children I say the sex offenders are at
a fault sell all of their things give
that money to the victims but in a
qualified immunity setting what it means
is when people are doing their job and
making close professional calls it's
wrong to hold them accountable civilly
when they're using the best information
they have at the time so qualified
immunity protects people like police
officers and Children Services Workers
from frivolous lawsuits or from claims
that are better brought against the real
villain here which of course are the sex
offenders who did these evil crimes yeah
well Terry talking about students the
plaintiffs have sued under section 1983
I'm not familiar with that what exactly
is a 1983 claim and what do the
plaintiff need to demonstrate in order
to Prevail well it's more a process the
1983 claim but it gives an individual
the right to sue a state state employee
as long as that state employee is acting
under what they call the color of Law
and it is to protect a constitutional
right and here it's life liberty and
personal security of those children and
so I think as long as we can show here
in this case or at least the plaintiff
can show in this case that these
individuals were working under color of
law under state law and that they were
negligent and that they did not protect
the children I think there's a good
chance that they could Prevail and you
know I spoke to this attorney and she's
adamant about these claims she's adamant
that the state agency is pointing the
finger at their subcontractors who
actually investigated these individuals
and allowed them to continue you know
working in the Foster system
yeah
um definitely we got to protect these
children one way or another Mark Terry
thank you very much for joining us as
always and thank you for joining us here
at long crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign